I'm sure most of you know and I don't
have to tell you that these are not
particularly bright days for the human
race and there are multi-level stories
here there's the the sort of full macro
of the world pandemic there's the micro
of how or how our individual lives are
being affected and then sort of in the
middle is how our specific country is
being led or or maybe more accurately
not led and lied to daily by the
president that we elected I would not me
personally not many of you either but as
a country this person that we elected
and we're going to be looking through
all of these multi-level lenses and
perspectives today but I want to start
with what is increasingly the largest
and most destructive source of
disinformation around the virus which is
unfortunately Donald Trump himself
Donald Trump's press briefings which
we've been covering live and I hope that
you've been joining me for some of them
are riddled with lies and attacks on
journalists and are pushing out actual
doctors and scientists who are trying to
tell us the truth trying to help the
situation and instead filled with Donald
Trump telling lies and insulting people
and the number of official cases in the
United States is exploding of course the
more we test the more cases we find
because we've been so behind on testing
the number of deaths is climbing every
single day and we can't even get
straight answers about have you sent
ventilators to hospitals how many have
you sent masks to hospitals from the
stockpile you talk about testing
capacity coming online every day you say
by the end of the week we will be here
and then at the end of the week we ask
you and you say well let's not really
focus on the numbers we are bringing on
additional capacity and over the weekend
Donald Trump added worse to worst by
unleashing a historically unhinged tweet
storm riddled with propaganda and
signaling that the White House is fully
switching from 50/50 propaganda and
policy a policy to deal with the virus
to exclusively propagandizing
this pandemic crisis so let's look at
some of the highlights and because
Donald Trump has almost nothing on his
schedule these days other than a daily
briefing usually one call with
governor's or one call with FEMA today I
looked at from schedule this morning all
he has is a briefing at 5:30 p.m.
Eastern today and lunch with Mike Pence
that's it that's all that Donald Trump
is doing he has a lot of time to tweet
Trump tweeting a completely fact free
video from Fox News propagandist Jesse
Watters with the comment in all capital
letters Chinese virus fact check Trump
attacking governor's Trump attacking any
governor who says hey Trump might not be
doing enough here saying governor of
Illinois and a very small group of
certain other governors together with
fake news CNN and con cast calling
comcast comcast MC DNC shouldn't be
blaming the federal government for their
own shortcomings we are there to back
you up should you fail and always wid
will be in the midst of this Trump
retweeting about 10 propaganda tweets
from Republican Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell also riddled with
disinformation and lies and political
posturing rather than dealing with the
public health to call it a crisis seems
almost not strong enough Trump then
tweeting a thank-you to right-wing
extremist channel Oh a N one American
news which has been tossing softball
questions at Donald Trump during the
coronavirus hearings saying Thank You
Jenn Falik RINO Oh a n for throwing him
a bogus question of course about how
everyone is just being so unfair to him
during the recent press briefing now
this next one I want to be careful with
because it actually requires more
analysis which we will do later Trump
tweeting about a possible possible
treatment for the virus saying
hydroxychloroquine and as if throw mice
and taken together have a real chance to
be one of the biggest game changers in
the history of medicine like that's
completely hyperbolic we're going to
talk about that as a possible treatment
but that's so hyperbolic Trump saying
the FDA has
move mountains thank you hopefully they
will both work hydroxychloroquine better
with azithromycin International Journal
of antimicrobial agents be put in use
immediately people are dying move fast
and god bless everyone we'll deal with
that in detail later so what we realized
as if we didn't know it from the last 38
months what we realized over the last
three days is we're in a real crisis now
this is not acting you know lying about
the deficit this is a real crisis we
don't have a leader we have a confused
70 year old man who has no idea what's
going on doesn't listen to medical
experts thinks he knows more and this is
not a game anymore now it already wasn't
the game when kids were in cages I
understand that it hasn't been a game
for a while now but there's a new
dimension in which this is no longer a
game Trump needs to step away from kovat
let Anthony foul to take over appoint
obama's ebola czar Ronald clean as Cove
odds are Trump must be removed from the
presidency but if not that he has to be
distanced from the Cova da schoo and
this is one of the things I want to dig
into now this episode is sponsored by
blue Chu one of the things I make a
priority on the show is not to
perpetuate stigma for things that don't
deserve it we've talked about mental
health we've talked about many things
where we should all just be respectful
adults period and we would be better off
and blue Tru can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for blue to calm blue
like the color blue is the first
chewable with the same fda-approved
ingredient as in Viagra and Cialis it
can be taken day or night even on a full
stomach since it's chewable it works
twice as fast as a pill whenever the
opportunity arises blue chew is
prescribed online by licensed doctors
you don't have to go to a doctor's
office you don't have to wait in line at
a pharmacy it ships right to your door
in a discreet package they're made in
the USA and since blue troop repairs and
ships direct it's cheaper than a
pharmacy and best of all no more
awkwardness we've got a special deal for
our viewers and listeners go to blue to
comm get your first shipment
when you use our promo code Pakman
that's PA que ma n pages $5 shipping
that's blue2 dot-com promo code Pakman
to try it totally free blue chew is the
better cheaper faster choice and we
thank them for sponsoring the David
Pakman show